previously on TV sins Wow that is a
surprise just one little question out
why not Ross's room
lest we forget once you're out the front
door you're still in the middle of the
[ __ ] desert the Dunphy's house is so
over landscape that could use it for the
set of Jumanji free I still know what
you did last Jumanji sitcom pratfall has
two pratfall but how exactly did Claire
lose the bowl here she had cleared the
door does she have a fear of open
refrigerator doors because that plotline
would be a lot more interesting and
original than dealing with daughters
first boyfriend son being taught a
lesson
stepfather learning to be a better
stepfather dad letting him to be
understanding to his gay son and
understanding other cultures honey do
you have anything to say to your
daughter about her skirt
claire has apparently been to a modest
is hottest seminar recently and will now
make her daughter and other girls
watching feel self-conscious about their
body image but hey jokes sir again
good baby our bedside took I don't know
find it if the joke here is that mom and
dad are using the baby oil for when it's
time to do the dirty dumpy dance I just
like to point out that baby oil is not
intended for use in intimate areas and
can cause infection feel free to use
Lube but be mature enough to go buy some
meant for sexy time I just don't want my
kids to make the same bad mistakes
I mean parenting their kid to grow up
like them cliche is the number one
village in no Colombia for all their
whatsoever murders this [ __ ] has its
share of issues one of the big problems
is it's never quite as funny or inspired
as it thinks it is however the chemistry
between Ed O'Neill and Sofia Vergara is
electric and deserves us in all sorry
for the manis plating here but if you're
gonna blame someone blame that goalie
you should have covered that ball easily
I've wanted to tell her off the last six
weeks attempting to pick up a mom while
wearing knockoff ed hardy gear at a kids
soccer game feels like it should be a
cinch we just adopted her from Vietnam
Vietnam does not allow adoption by
same-sex parents not only is this a sin
for accuracy it's a sin for
closed-minded people wherever they may
live we have been together for five five
years now
the previous introductions listed the
timeline as a subtitle and Mitch has to
say how long he and cam have been
together just saying if you're going to
present the fake documentary format
let's have some fake documentary
see then we think they're already mean
enough can you imagine one of them
pregnant
that's just a schist you know I'm gonna
get the speech the sitting Mitch is
currently talking at full volume pretty
sure most people already heard the
comment about how insensitive they were
once cam came aboard rushing listing
credits by text lol laugh out loud
oMG oh my god WTF why the face okay fine
the writing on the show sharp and Ty
Burrell is freaking hilarious take your
sin off you rapscallions you considering
up pretty much every viewer probably
wanted to shoot Alex with a plastic baby
after this pilot I feel like Claire and
Phil should give Luke a break and since
they don't know I'm a dick we'll go
ahead and send that miscarriage of
justice for Luke you can shoot him
afterwards we'll be home at two I can't
shoot him at - I'm throwing a house a -
what about three no he's in a soccer
game at three as funny as this family
calendar bit isn't you could have shot
Luke ten times with that BB gun and the
time it's ticking it a fake argue about
scheduling Manny would be great at TV
since also this adult the kids body
stick is pretty funny good thing the
show won't be on the air long enough for
Manny to outgrow the bit but have the
writer is still trying to pull it off
when he's in his 20s that'll never
happen
what the hell Cam and Mitchell have a
night-vision camera set up in their
pantry or is this insinuating the
production team put it there either way
I repeat what the hell this episode is
67% Claire folding laundry oh look it's
the boom mic operator but yes I know
it's a mockumentary but even so them
should be hidden and while we're at it
this whole document anything is a joke
of a conceit originally they were
planning on it being because a dutch
director that had lived with the dumpees
came back to film them but then they
were like now audiences won't care we'll
just uses a lazy storytelling device
without ever once explaining it well
welcome to Judgment Day [ __ ] Phil
sweetie honey he is Dylan and he is a
senior and you are holding on to this
teenage kids hand for an uncomfortable
amount of time yes at all mall walking
stay to the right
mall walkers so you know family got
pregnant would you ever pretend she has
mono for a few months and then like tell
everyone the baby's yours just wait a
few seasons the writers are sure to run
out of ideas pretty quickly and then we
can find out buddy what are you wearing
nothing I know Luke's not supposed to be
the sharpest Dumpty in the [ __ ] but if
he thought to cover himself up this well
surely he would have figured out a way
to get his naked legs as well a minute
you're just friends watching falcon
crest in the next year
underneath the air hockey table with you
Brian pocket uh yes Falcon Crest the 80s
aphrodisiac the number of babies made to
the heated discussions between Chase and
Maggie about the wine industry is
impossible to calculate you come into my
house and you insult me and my boyfriend
who by the way is not that dramatic
still better than the Disney remake
we're from different worlds yet we
somehow fit together
Nakia van repo narration mocker nation I
don't have friends family seriously not
to be the evil stepdad if I was the
mailman I'd be having your wife buddy
what are you wearing
Randy lay there like a slug it was his
only defense come on Jack don't pretend
it's not me think I'd shoot you Jack
please don't make me do this